It really pains me to say this, but ISIS is
on the verge of experiencing a revival.
And this is not the type of news that maybe
we expected to have to bring you even as recently
as six months ago.
And it is all thanks to Donald Trump's recent
decision to pull troops from Northern Syria
and it is an absolute unmitigated disaster.
The French prime minister now says that the
reemergence of ISIS is inevitable.
Saying, quote, this is devastating for our
security with the inevitable resurgence of
Islamic state in Northeastern Syria and probably
also Northwest Iraq.
And so the destabilization have a government
that doesn't need that.
That's Edward Felipe, the French prime minister
yesterday.
What is he talking about?
Well, as I told you yesterday, thanks to Donald
Trump's decision to bail in Northern Syria,
hundreds of the relatives of Vice's members
escaped from Kurdish held camps.
Donald Trump reacting by claiming that it
is that curds are deliberately releasing ISIS
associated people in order to draw the United
States back into the region.
Now, that's a conspiracy theory with absolutely
no evidence supporting it in case you didn't
immediately realize that there's no evidence
for Donald Trump's claim whatsoever.
And once again, we very quickly have a coalition
that is building and it is a coalition on
which the United States is on the wrong side.
Trump bailing in Syria is an opening to Turkey
to absolutely slaughter the Kurds, which they're
doing, which they started doing within hours
of Donald Trump's pullback.
Other countries involving many of our historical
democratic allies are uniting against Turkey,
France, Italy, Germany, Finland, Sweden, all
stopping weapons sales to Turkey immediately.
The United Kingdom considering similar action.
And meanwhile, Donald Trump has gotten out
of the way of Turkey so that Turkey can do
untold levels of violence against the Kurds,
which they did as soon as Donald Trump gave
them that opportunity.
Last week, Donald Trump is undoing the fight
against ISIS after bragging for two years
that he took ISIS out.
Now, if we want to speculate about the underlying
reasons for Trump doing this last night on
my live stream, which was prematurely ended
by the way, um, I was asked about some of
the motivations for why Donald Trump took
this action.
There is a wide ranging list of possibilities.
What we do know is that Donald Trump made
this decision to pull troops from Northern
Syria despite it not being recommended by
anyone who was in the know.
His generals, as Donald Trump likes to say,
did not recommend this decision.
Uh, this action, the state department did
not recommend pulling troops from Northern
Syria.
So it leaves us to wonder, any reasonable
person would say, well, if none of the experts
are recommending Trump do this, why did he
do it?
And then we start to speculate.
Does Ertl wan have something so bad on the
killing of Jamal Shoji that if it were to
get out, it would be even more devastating
that Donald Trump didn't do a damn thing about
it.
Instead selling more weapons to Saudi Arabia?
It's a possibility.
Is it, once again, Donald Trump lining up
with what Putin wants?
Putin, of course, a supporter of dictator
Bashar Al Assad in Syria, who is of course
on the opposite side of the Kurds, who now
are being slaughtered by, uh, the Turkish
Turkish forces.
That's a possibility.
Could it have been motivated by trying to
prevent Putin from releasing, you know, some
compromising materials that he might have
on Donald Trump.
That's merely a speculative thing.
We also have seen no evidence that Donald
Trump is capable of feeling shame.
So the possibility of shame maybe is not,
uh, the best explanation for why Donald Trump
might do what he did.
Is it merely financial, as is often the case
with Donald Trump, Trump, of course, having
his hotel in Turkey, there's financial quid
pro quo may be involving the Turkish government
and Trump does this in exchange for, I don't
know, Turkey letting him keep his Trump tower
open.
There were speculating.
What we know is that the action makes no sense
and we've gotten no suitable explanation for
why Donald Trump has done this.
I again, lean more towards the financial,
uh, rather than to prevent embarrassing stuff
from being released.
Because I've not seen evidence that Donald
Trump is truly capable of feeling shame.
We've seen him get very angry when he feels
that someone has been disloyal.
A normal person would also feel ashamed by
some of the stuff that has gone on.
But for Trump, it seems to be mostly anger.
I don't know the answer.
What do you think is behind this?
If you're watching on YouTube, leave a comment,
giving me your idea.
Otherwise, send me a tweet
at the Pacman and of course, of course, make
sure you're following the David Pakman show
on Instagram at David captains, Jeff